Monica Lewinsky is back she's a producer
on the upcoming season of American crime
story it's gonna focus on her infamous
affair with Bill Clinton and get this
it's set to air a little over a month
before the 20/20 election Greg you were
saying some things well I'm excited I
mean she should be producing it she's
the closest person to this story she
should play herself and Bill Clinton
should play himself
there could be everybody great be like a
real Ian of a reality show no where are
they now we know where they should be
she was great or was it the Clinton
affair that yeah her life story is is
remarkable and she has not been able to
make a living for herself in a way that
she would have wanted because of this
would happen to her when she was in
college and an intern and what I really
appreciate is that the producer of the
American crime story said to her I don't
want anybody else to tell this story you
should be the one to tell your story and
he invited her to be a producer of the
show I think that's great this is one of
those moments in cable where like
someone on Twitter will say you know
there's a massive shooting going on in
Fox News is doing Lewinsky yeah this is
like what they're gonna get us for but
we did that other stuff at the top of
the show Donna well first of all we just
saw when they see us on Netflix and that
was about the Central Park five
featuring Donald Trump who took out a
story I read in the New York Times so
look this is the heir of the me to
movement I'm not surprised so back to
the Monica Murphy's who is producing
this I watched the People vs OJ Simpson
and Sarah Paulsen is the one who is
going to play will Linda Tripp Sarah
Paulson won an Emmy for playing Marcia
and it was fascinating to watch because
it's a story that you've really never
heard told and that's new information it
was Sarah Paulson who is brilliant
and I will watch it just for her and
nobody should have will have a five
watch party yeah there you go
Greg are you sure you don't have
anything else no I don't want to are you
sure right to get me to say something
that will get me behind the bubble and
I'm not gonna do it okay and why are we
looking this show with James Taylor
that's a great that's a great song